Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Spanish-speaking experts
from Latin America
will show you
some of our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
This course is divided
into five parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn along.
Let's get it started.
Hello. Welcome back to the
HTML5 web development
on Google Drive
introduction course.
My name is
Cesar Anton Dorantes,
Google Developer Expert
for the Google Drive platform.
In this lesson we will see
the following subjects:
introduction to Google Charts,
my first chart
with Google Table Charts,
Google Pie Charts,
and finally, a practice
in which we'll build
your first HTML5 app
with Google Charts.
You ready? Here we go!
Google Charts offers a simple
and professional way
to visualize the data
on a website or web app.
Google Charts has
an extended library
that offers charts to cover
all important points
and a bit more,
from line charts,
bar charts or pie charts,
to powerful dashboards,
and the very popular geocharts.
The most common way
to develop with Google Charts
is using JavaScript.
In order to do this,
we load the libraries
according to the type of chart
we wish to use,
we introduce the data
we wish to show,
we customize the charts the way
they best adapt to our needs,
and we finally create
a chart object
with an ID we choose.
We will use it to call the chart
from our HTML code.
Pretty soon you'll see
how easy it is to do this
thanks to the incredible
Visualization API.
Charts are declared
as classes in JavaScript
and Google Charts has
an extended library
so you can always
represent your data
in the best way.
Usually, the by-default
appearance will be enough
but we can customize it
to adjust it
more precisely to our data
and to our page
or web app style.
Google Charts generates
interactive charts
capable of triggering
different types of events
that allow us to connect
several visualizations
so we can create
powerful dashboards,
and we can also connect it
with our own code
to give a very
dynamic experience
from our website or web app.
All charts receive their data
by using a class
called dataTable,
which allows us to easily
change the chart type
until finally finding the one
that adjusts to our data.
It also lets us represent
the same data
by using several graphs.
A quite common example
would be showing a chart
and a pie graph
to represent our data
in the clearest way possible.
Incredible, right?
Let's move on
to programming our first app
in Google Charts.
Let's start by declaring
the necessary HTML
for our presentation.
I recommend you recycle
the code you built last time.
MY FIRST CHART
WITH GOOGLE TABLE CHARTS
First, we need to import
Google's API
and then select the library
that we will be needing.
We'll start with the most
common representation,
Table Charts.
All this with just 4
very simple code lines.
Time to start using JavaScript.
In this example, we'll name
our file charts.js.
We'll start by declaring the data
we will represent
within the variable data,
contained in a function
called drawVisualization.
For our example, we'll show
how we usually distribute
the hours throughout our day.
Notice we introduce the data
using a JSON ordered array,
within a method called
arrayToDataTable.
The first line corresponds
to the headings in the table
and the rest are
the subsequent lines.
Now we need to declare
a TableChart-type visualization
to which we will assign
the ID "chart",
which we'll use later on
to designate
in which part of the app
we're going to show the chart.
We also need to put,
always at the end of the code,
the method
google.setOnLoadCallback
and put the name
of our function
in the parenthesis.
What this does is wait for
everything to correctly load
before ordering
the drawing of the graphs.
Turn for the CSS.
Let's remember that CSS
allows us to declare
the visual characteristics
for the elements
in our HTML5 projects.
In this case we'll use it
to determine the chart's area.
For this we create a class
named charts
and we assign the width
and height for our chart.
Time to go back
to our HTML code.
Let's start by indicating
the route to the files
we just created.
Remember to do this in the
G section of your HTML code.
Remember the ID
we assigned the chart
in the JavaScript code?
Now it's time to use it
to declare
in which part we want
this chart to be shown.
We will also use the class
we declared in our CSS
to determine the area
it will occupy.
Did you notice something
very important
is missing in the HTML5?
That's right!
The "article" tag we saw
in last lesson,
which indicates the main
contents in our page.
This time we'll also use
the "header" tag
to point the heading
for our application.
Though this is totally optional,
it's a recommended practice
in HTML5
and is particularly useful
when we're embellishing
our code with CS3.
In the beginning of this lesson
we said you can use
the same Data Table to draw
different presentations
of the data at the same time.
And now it's time
to put this to the test
by adding a pie chart
to our app.
The first thing to do is
to declare a new visualization
in our file charts.js,
but this time we will use
PieChart instead of Table.
To give it a little
more presentation,
we'll add a title that says:
"How do you use your day?"
Let's go back to our HTML code.
In order to add the pie chart,
we first need
to add the corechart library
alongside to the table one
in section G of our code.
Then, we just select
in which part we wish
the chart to be drawn
by using the ID we chose,
in this case, pie,
and that's it,
we already have an app
that shows our data
in two different ways.
It was really easy, right?
I invite you to watch
this lesson again,
this time making pauses
to follow the steps
and copying the code
that is shown.
For a comparison,
you can see an example
in the website shown on screen.
This will be it for now.
See you next time with:
"Connecting your app
with Google Spreadsheets,"
where we'll learn to import
data in real time
from Google Spreadsheets.
And if you liked this lesson,
you'll just love next one.
I say goodbye for now
and remember:
keep on programming!